[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm very excited to be here two parts of
my talk rely on real-time communication
between my phone my laptop and your
laptops and the Wi-Fi seems to be
operating by courier pigeon here so
perhaps if you could turn off the Wi-Fi
on your laptops just for the duration of
this talk look at this room for the
phones to actually work and it's just
stopped working okay all right so I work
for intercom in Dublin Ireland we also
have offices in San Francisco and London
you might recognize us from our
messenger which is in the bottom
right-hand corner of a lots of great web
businesses it's a react app to pay two
and a half years old we also have quite
a large amber app which is the app that
our customers use day in day out and
it's four and a half years old unlike
most amber apps that follow the six week
upgrade release cycle it's never been
healthier in terms of codebase
having had quite a few chats with some
of you in the last couple of days I know
a lot of you work for great companies
I'm proud to say the intercom is also a
great company we've a strong ambition to
become one of the great technology
companies unlike all great companies we
like to share our ideas these are some
books that we publish as an example
sharing stories helps us attract amazing
people to intercom everyone who joins
our under into under anniversary their
entry to get an inter comic which kind
of celebrates some of the impact and fun
that they've had over a year these are
my four inter comics they're all amber
themed the reason I'm telling you this
in a little more detail than I normally
would is to give you some background for
this conference talk each year we hold a
series of
dr. focus events across the world where
we share our approach to building
products that hopefully people love this
picture is from San Francisco and this
is London and Dublin and in November
last year again in Dublin in famous
vicar street we had a first set of
technical talks about our approach to
building and iterating products in
income this was a really amazing night
it was more like a Radiohead concert
than a typical tech event I'm forward I
wanted to come up with something a
little different and hopefully fun I
think it's amazing that we get to live
in a time where it's possible to build
an impactful career where the work
rarely feels like work and I just want
to have a little fun with my talk so
this was the first slide of my talk
gonna be good intro to the rest of this
talk my slides are an Amber app running
on my laptop I'm also running the same
app on my phone which allows me to
control the presentation I'll soon ask
you to open the same web app on your
phones too so you can interact with the
presentation so when I trigger drum
sound on my phone will send real-time
messages to all connected phones and
these messages are being relayed through
a simple socket I own node server which
is running in Amazon's California data
center so the initial part of my talk
that I gave in Dublin went pretty well
this was a high point then a few seconds
later it actually no longer works
so the server crashed I'd no way to get
the presentation running again so I
couldn't complete the second part of my
12th Jan not a huge deal one of the
themes of that night was risk-taking
this was a little bit of a risk
after go home I realized my mistake I
was missing a guard there was a race
condition and an exception brought down
the server at the time I hadn't done
much node I've done a little more now
hopefully that is a lesson learned
we'll see so I got to give my talk a
second time earlier in the year and
eMERCOM from Portland happily all the
major parts of the talk worked through a
few little issues luckily they were
mostly minor UI issues and the broadly
worked as I'd hoped as luck would have
it the third instrument the orange one
at the bottom
I was actually controlled by someone in
Zimbabwe there was a live stream and
Lennox happened to be you know picked
randomly which is pretty special
so before we try to here I want to talk
a little bit about the software that
allows these presentations to be created
since amber calm I've begun extracting
the guts there of that talk into an
Amber add-on called Amber present and it
allows anyone to create rich interactive
real-time presentations with Amber
components so amber knew to create an
ember app and reinstall amber present
allows it to become a slideshow an Amber
generate slide will generate at the root
and the components so presentation
slides are defined much like amber
routes just with slide instead of Rouge
and slide contents are defined in
so with a little content in style here's
those exact slides and as presentations
can be interactive they can also can
define multiple roles so in this case
there is a presenter role in a screen
role and running locally this is what
that looks like and here's what this
talked and giving right now looks like
when running locally so at the top is
the screen on the very left is my phone
and then for phones in the audience as
you can see it's it's real-time it's
very easy to create like real-time polls
and things of that there's other useful
components so components for doing code
with highlighting and video components
and as real-time controls for playback
or setting sections and I can yeah by
pressing button change the video not
particularly useful you can do things
like change your background color in
real time as well I'm just clicking a
button there and represent comes with
tailwind CS CSS so it's very easy to
spin up and style slides and this should
help adding themes which I hope to do
soon slides scale keepo 69 ratio and
it's also because it's real-time I can
do like a real-time pointer this is an
animated slide that I created for
another talk that I gave two years ago
an animated guide to ember and the thing
I'm most excited about and I only
recently realized that whatever present
is the possibility of publishing
presentations as NPM packages and
allowing others to import them into
their own presentations and reusing them
so I've created a lot of animations like
this that have only been seen once and
hopefully it can be useful to other
people when going to like local meetups
or conferences or whatever if you saw
Chad's talk on compilers this morning
and performance this is a visualization
I made of a earlier version of the
glimmer VM and I'm kind of showing it
now because I wanted to be seen in a
second time because it took me like two
weeks to make it's a little out of date
now but it's showing the inner workings
of the glimmer VM as if initially
rendered as a page so I'm hoping to redo
these animations to bring them up to the
latest glimmer version so that other
people can use them
here's another example this is Alex Alex
Marcin ear giving a great talk on his
ember concurrency add-on and his
presentation was a custom-built Hammer
app to demonstrate his this was a real
inspiration to me at the time I wanted
to be able to put amber into my
presentations like his so with his
permission yesterday i extracted some of
his components from his talk into and
amber presented on so here are those
slides here so you can just amber
install that add-on and you you get
slides like this so briefly amber
concurrency is a add-on for an API
declarative API for constraining
concurrent tasks and the core primitive
is tasks which accept generator
functions so in this case it's just a
simple function that waits for two
seconds and I can click perform here and
actually you can see a visualization of
this running so by default they all run
concurrently amber concurrency isn't
doing anything but we get these task
modifiers so here is the drop modifier
and you can see if I run this it well if
there's already an instance of a task
running it will drop you tasks until
it's it's clear
here's another modifier and cue and you
can guess what that does accuse them up
and probably the most reason we are most
commonly used one is restartable it
could be used for like depends search
and things that as a final example in
amber camp this year
Edward Falconer introduced his new
add-on amber animation so like where
amber concurrency I created a few slides
to demonstrate this as well so I the
left and right button here and if I
click left you'll see one of the logos
randomly will move from less than the
right to the left if I hit it a few
times left and right they kind of do a
dance which is cool the amazing thing
about amber animated is that all I'm
doing here is defining where the list
should be rendered and then removing an
item and inserting it into your array in
a random location and the natural
movement emerges from the sprites which
are coordinating behind the scenes and
this animation these animations can also
happen across routes here as we saw
there so amber and I made it as a core
primitive within amber present so soon
it will be easy to have nice animations
between slides
alright so live demo time it's 2018 it's
like this will maybe work I don't know
if you'd like to participate please take
out your phone and load this web address
bitly slash JSC 1:8 when it loads you
can enter your name just click Next if
your name is taken just put in a random
name will be triggering sounds in your
phone so please turn up the volume and
you can press the buttons to test the
sound locally if you get an iPhone you
mean it may need to flip the lid the
mute switch you can see in the top right
there's a count of the number of people
connected I know there's maybe 200
people in the rim so this demo will work
best if your phone doesn't go to sleep
so every now and again you'll get a
little reminder just to touch the screen
to keep it awake if it's not working VA
for some reason perhaps you could record
some minutes for Twitter presuming it
works alright so this is a simple
example of triggering real-time drums on
your phones every time I press a button
they'll send real-time messages to your
phone to play a particular sound alright
notice that the drum sounds are all
playing at the same time we're all
connected where we're connected to
arrange different networks or mobile
networks and even if we're on the same
network there's a range of different
Layton sees even on a single phone from
one request to the next and this will be
even clearer if I trigger drumbeat to
play and this will probably sound pretty
bad
yeah you can visualize the different
latencies on your phones by running some
tests so if you can click the test
latency button on your phone and it'll
do a series of request responses with
the real-time server and you'll likely
see some variance in your own device
hey the graph is sorted all right so
what's this saying
most people are under 100 milliseconds
which bodes pretty well I think for the
rest of the talk so one approach to
dealing with latency is to get a shared
understanding of what time it is on all
the phones if we can do that we can
schedule stands to play at a particular
time so phones generally keep the same
time but there's still enough of a
difference across phones that it would
wouldn't work for a drum machine and
what we can't do though is ping the
server and measure how long it takes so
let's assume 20 milliseconds in toll and
we can assume that a request hop takes
about half the times 10 milliseconds and
if the server includes its time in the
response and we add the 10 milliseconds
to that and the phone has a pretty good
understanding of what time it is
compared to the server so this is the
strategy we took when we run those
latency tests in your phone this graph
is showing the difference in time across
phones so phones on the Left are behind
the server time phones on the right are
ahead of it pretty amazing that
everyone's almost on the same time so
let's see if it works let's see if it's
any better so I'll trigger trigger some
sounds to play but in 1 seconds time
that seems better let's try the drum
machine
all right thanks so actually when I've
done that before this has more like
that's not meant to work as well well
let me try just the iPhones alright
that's pretty good and the androids oh
right and the androids well that's the
best Android is everyone I mean I I love
Android but their latency see I don't
think it's a real word but if it was I
think there's a it this is kind of a
audio lies ation of Android
fragmentation just like an iOS the
operating system receives our JavaScript
function to execute the send is received
and queued up at the right time it's
just that there's a range of different
onboard Layton sees when it comes to
stand on androids one of the reasons why
different lag times are so noticeable is
that drum sounds have got a really sharp
attack time meaning all that sound kind
of happens at once if we take a sound
that's got a more gradual attack like
orchestral sounds and it allows us some
leeway with the latency so I've put
together twelve different orchestral
sounds from a section of Beethoven's
fifth symphony which I'll randomly
assign to different devices now alright
so this is about 40 seconds here we go
it worked
[Music]
all right now we have the phone synced
up let's bring in the house speakers so
if you could choose which section of the
room you're in so left middle or right
if you'd like to participate so I'm
going to randomly assign some MIDI
devices which are running on my machine
so this is a piece of software called
Ableton Live which is a digital audio
workstation which is predominantly used
for generating and performing electronic
music and I've created a short track for
this talk and others using for
synthesizers which you can see here if I
just play
okay okay odyo is working okay so the
black area on the right is also running
the same ember up just in a different
role and I'm also running a local node
server which is subscribed to real-time
events and it translates these events
into MIDI signals which are sent to
Ableton Live so I've arranged it so for
people and the audience can control
different parts that he synthesizes so
I'm gonna select someone at random
alright bthe sorcerer you move cool so
I'm gonna solo your instrument and
enable the chorus and press play you can
explore the four corners the yellow box
on the screen is where I put the
parameter when I was recording it but
you can put it anywhere you want music
his expression so let's pick someone
else for Pat - okay JP so let's try year
1 okay it's a similar synth but it's got
different characteristics okay that's
the third instrument okay Dan here we go
okay I'm down you're in smell will come
in after like 10 or 12 seconds you'll
get you'll see it on the screen so let's
pick a fourth instrument okay let me try
okay that could just be random luck yeah
it was okay Benham your your instrument
number three done you're promoted to
number four
okay so let's see some buttons here go
to intro alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right it sounds better when I
recorded it okay congratulations thanks
everyone thanks for that so that's all I
have thanks very much
[Applause]